- [Instructor] We're asked
which of the following options
have the same value as 2% of 90?
Pause this video, and see
if you can figure it out.
And as a reminder, they
say, pick two answers.
All right, now let's work
through this together.
So before I even look at the choices,
I'm just going to try to
think of all of the ways
that I can write 2% of 90.
2%, this right over here,
this literally means two per 100.
So I could view it as the
same thing as two over 100,
times 90, that's one
way to write 2% of 90.
Two over a 100,
I can divide both the numerator
and the denominator by two.
And so two over a 100
is also the same thing
as one over 50.
And so it could also be
one over 50, times 90.
Now let's see what other
choices they have here.
Well, I could also write 2% as a decimal.
Two-hundredths should
be written like this.
Zero point, this is the tenths place.
I have no tenths, but
I have two-hundredths.
So I'm multiplying that by 90.
All of these right over here
are equivalent to the 2%, 2% of 90.
All right, now let's look at the choices.
This is 0.2 times 90.
This is not 2%.
This actually would be two-tenths, or 20%.
So let me rule that one out.
This one right over here.
This is two-hundredths times 90.
We already wrote that down.
I like this choice.
200 times 90.
No, that would be far larger
than what we are looking for.
We are looking for two-hundredths,
not two hundreds times 90,
so definitely rule that one out.
Two times 90.
Well, no, we're looking for
2% of 90, not two times 90.
Once again, this is too large.
And then we have two-hundredths times 90,
which is the first thing that we wrote.
And so I like this choice as well.